it's a time-honored tradition to watch
horror films in October but spooky good
times that the movies don't have to wait
until Halloween to make sure you're
keeping up with the best new horror
movies in the genre we've got a list of
the best horror movies of 2018 so far
annihilation
subtlety and style don't often rule the
box-office particularly when it comes to
the horror landscape which is dominated
by in-your-face lashes squeamish torture
marathons and gritty found footage
attics it can come as a pleasant
surprise then when a movie gets enough
of a budget for some striking visuals
while remaining quiet enough to leave
you with lingering questions and a
genuine sense of unease Alex Garland an
author and screenwriter who made his
directorial debut with the 2015 sci-fi
sleeper hit ex machina returned in 2018
with annihilation the movie follows a
group of scientists investigating a
mysterious disaster zone filled with
strange creatures hailed by critics with
phrases like nightmare fuel Ghul and
sophomore effort deftly blends a
metaphor laced space invasion story with
creeping dread and uncanny imagery that
was a financial disappointment in
theaters word of mouth has continued to
build around annihilation since its home
release adding a cast of fan favorite
actors like Natalie Portman Tessa
Thompson and Oscar Isaac and
annihilation is one of the scariest and
strangest movies you'll see all year who
wasn't destroying
who is changing everything he was making
something new upgrade in a not too
distant future where computer assisted
body modification is the norm gray
played by Logan Marshall Green remained
staunchly defensive of his own humanity
refusing to become augmented that is
until an attack leaves him
wheelchair-bound and his wife dead enter
a mysterious tech innovator who offers
to restore Gray's motor functions with
his newest AI chip as any horror
aficionado could guess this melding of
man and machine has some gruesome
results directed by Leigh Whannell of
saw Fame and produced by genre
juggernaut Blum house upgrade blends
topical concerns with an old-fashioned
sense of gritty grind house spun wildly
the feature debut from director Fritz
bone wildling is anchored by stunning
performances from genre favorites Brad
Dourif and Liv Tyler Bell poly takes the
lead as Anna a teenage girl who's grown
up under the abusive thumb of the father
figure who claims to be protecting her
from man-eating creatures outside when
she's rescued by the local sheriff
played by Tyler Anna begins to realized
that the stories were true in a way
wildling has been hailed by critics for
its powerhouse performances and striking
visuals The Hollywood Reporter listed it
as one of the 10 best films debuting at
South by Southwest and it's hard to
argue with the mountain of praise the
movie has earned the wildling what's the
wildling heats children ghost stories
after the 1980s saw the release of the
cult favorite Creepshow horror anthology
films went mostly dormant luckily recent
years have seen a revival of the formula
with trick-or-treat and the VHS series
bringing the horror anthology back to
mainstream audiences in 2018 American
audiences were treated to a new British
horror anthology ghost stories the
project began its life as a stage play
but Andy Dimon and Jeremy Dyson who
shared writing and directing duties on
the finished film the story follows a
professor known for debunking hoaxes
as he investigates three cases of
alleged paranormal activity the lines
between reality and fiction blur as the
anthology builds to a startling surreal
climax
that's absolutely jaw-dropping a quiet
place directed and co-written by John
Krasinski a quiet place captured the
attention of audiences and critics when
it crept into theaters in April with a
clever premise and minimalist
presentation the film follows a family
trying to survive creatures that attack
anyone who makes a sound
Krasinski and cos the film as the stoic
patriarch trying to keep his family
alive in a role about as far away from
the officers jim halpert as it's
possible to get the film's cast is
rounded out with the stellar performance
by Emily Blunt you come on Noah jube and
young deaf actress
Millicent Simmons who made sure that the
film's portrayal of a deaf child
remained authentic
[Music]
kaga with the glut of zombie fare over
the past decade it's understandable that
a drama about The Walking Dead might get
lost in the shuffle cargo however brings
some fresh brains to the sub-genre with
a quiet story about one families post
outbreak life in rural Australia
directed by the filmmaking team of Ben
howling and yolanda ram ki and anchored
by an understated but intense
performance by Martin Freeman cargo is a
fitting descendant of George Romero's
original zombie films hereditary the
feature debut from writer director re
hasta hereditary sets out to unnerve you
with a cornucopia of disturbing omens
bizarre visuals and surreal nightmare
logic critics immediately got behind it
in a big way he being particular preys
on the lead performance by Toni Collette
she absolutely deserves the praise
giving a performance so overcome with
guilt and anger that you're likely to be
frightened even before anything
supernatural shows up swear it me don't
you ever raise your voice at me I am
your mother do you understand
[Music]